[Music]
water is an odorless tasteless liquid
humans are comprised of anywhere between
50 and 65 percent water water cover 71%
of the Earth's surface water has many
uses man without it we wouldn't have the
most popular beers on the market all of
those water establishing John's led to
something we could have just led with in
the first place someone about to
stupidly watch the video that kills you
after seven days by which I mean nyan
cat no you need to watch it now well he
sounds desperate are we about to find
out that he waited until the last
fucking minute to show someone else the
tape I mean I procrastinated in high
school too but this is some next-level
well I imagine he means the contents
that are actually on the videotape once
he played in the VCR not the actual
physical videotape the files are in the
computer kid leaves the room because
making sure that she actually watches
the tape would keep Naomi Watts from
finding out that people are still dying
because of this haunted videotape thus
preventing the movie from happening
also why didn't he put the tape in the
VCR and press play before leaving the
room this guy is putting way too much
faith in this girl to walk up and play
this tape all by herself smart house kid
has extended the same 5-minute grace
period as Joan of Arcadia and the first
movie we still haven't figured out what
happens to people if they just leave the
house when it's tomorrow runs out of the
TV to killya I'd like to see her keep up
with a Dodge Charger if her main method
of transportation is crawling yeah
creepy kid may have more color in his
face in this movie but he's still super
creepy without any CGI your makeup rock
special yeah wouldn't kill you to call
me Mom now and again this is an issue
that should have been resolved years ago
my question is why does he call her
Rachel every time he says something to
her even saying mom that much would be
too much I'd make a bonus round for this
Rachel
but everyone from me to you to YouTube
would die sure we have a yard family
moves into a new house in a horror movie
cliche there is no one standing in or
around the ambulance to keep Rachel from
walking right in while they were putting
the kid into the body bag a new
paramedic ran in with a sheep and was
super disappointed that they had already
put the kid in the bag knowing it was
his first day the supervisor says to him
it's okay Neil we can just put the sheet
over the body while it's in the body bag
30 seconds of body bag opening so after
Rachel made a copy of the ring tape at
the end of the last movie and the first
time anyone dies it just happens to be
in the small seaside town to which she
moved is this the first movie firmly
established that Samara only comes out
when she's killing someone who's seven
days are up but now she's just popping
out of body bags whenever she feels like
it
and given that Aiden is still alive they
showed it to someone and if they weren't
total dicks they would have told that
person how to avoid Samaras wrath which
would prompt that person to make a copy
triggering the worst pyramid scheme
since whatever skincare product your
annoying cousin has been messaging you
about on Facebook Emily just happens to
be within viewing distance after
Rachel's interaction with a cop it's
super convenient for Rachel that there
are never any cops around when she wants
to snoop and gather information
important to the movies plot we're
understaffed here I can't beat desk
sergeant and make sure people don't walk
back here that's Fred's job the house
we're within the last 24 hours a murder
occurred is not taped off or being
monitored by the police allowing Rachel
to snoop what she pleases movie expects
me to believe that rachel is able to
find a key to the house in the first
place she looks even if younger sharon
carter told her it's not like she was
Jake's girlfriend or anything she was
some stupid chick from class who
wouldn't know where the hide-a-key is
located after the last movie Rachel
thinks destroying the tape is something
that will work for some reason this is a
waste of everyone's time but especially
for actress Naomi Watts people video
tapes make tiny nazgul sounds when
they're being destroyed
you tell her Rachel it's time we told
these demons who don't play by the rules
of our physical realm where they can and
can't haunt people
this is way too obviously a dream
because none of it makes sense they'd
have to change the Samara rules to make
this real where she doesn't even need
the tape to transport into people's
lives oh wait so how does Samara know
where Eden is if this is some sort of
psychic ghost power that Samara used in
her short time in the ambulance with
Rachel none of this is ever explained
which will become a theme for this movie
all you have to do is call my name and
I'll follow your voice even if I have to
come right down into that nightmare with
you I believe what's Kraven called and
told you that would be copyright
infringement this movie is a massive
waste of time but still probably only
the one hundredth most wasteful of 2005
well isn't this the most amazing
collection of VHS movies ever assembled
all DreamWorks movies that is brand
loyalty that is missing in movie
libraries these days also collection
includes this bullsh movie in which some
asshole and cinemasins was an extra do
you're shadowing what was Rachel
expecting what happened when she let ate
and run off by himself earlier man I
haven't seen parenting this bad since
home alone this fly exists only to force
the viewer to make a connection to the
first movie at least that fly had
context this one is just randomly coming
out of an impossible place also if I saw
a fly in a she fairground bathroom in
any circumstance I doubt I would be
suspicious of something supernatural
happening did Samara simply wait until
Aidan and his mom randomly went to a
farmers market
antique show and for Aiden to walk into
an empty public bathroom before she
revealed herself when did this start was
it last night this morning mm-hmm
god damn it I'm beginning to think that
if her only child Aidan disappeared
Rachel would be a better person and a
better mom
also if Rachel is really concerned for
her kids she would keep her eyes on the
road when she drives was it your
nightmare you're sick all right and we
need to know what started it
mmm we just dealt with the supernatural
in the last movie I saw Samara come out
of Jake's body bag then I burned the
tape and now my kid is acting weirder
than usual actually the movie never
definitively answers this question
either so we just have to assume Samaras
back for financial reasons also didn't
Aiden have some sort of almost psychic
powers in the last movie why is it
Rachel asking her kid important
questions involving some owner and their
powers right now maybe she forgot the
first movie - you know the one who shall
not be named bald Amara Simard Oh Mort
hey guys I'd like to assure you that in
the first 30 minutes almost nothing
happens but there will be a deer attack
so you just got to be patient to get to
the good stuff I feel like the antlers
should be doing more killing Rachel here
that was the internal dialogue for this
deer he seems pretty chill just walking
away but then suddenly decided they were
working with I think the scariest part
of this scene is the thought of dealing
with the insurance company later also
car has never survived like this that
car is pink total but I think there was
a feature in the 1990 Volkswagen Jetta
called deer which specifically gave the
car deer murdering capabilities while
keeping most of your car intact it also
came with a CD player
good advice you seem to be failing to
heed right now for some reason even
after you witnessed it do your army
whaling on your car even more D
reinforcements show up late to the party
for some reason probably because they
were attending Bambi's funeral
motherfucker you guys already stopped
you've been stopped for nearly a full
minute now the correct command is go
but for some reason ritual continues not
not stopping guys we gave that mom and
her kid hell now just let them leave and
be sure to tell Barry and Gary down the
road not to detonate the hoof bomb so
far this movie is so stupid I'm gonna
make up a sin earlier when I scanned the
entire house in the small amount of
footage we were shown I never saw a
thermometer once so how do they have one
now magic was Samara not what enough
when she was there so she took the water
from the fish tank
if so then Samara is also addicted
goldfish my son is very sick and I'd
like to talk to someone who knows
directions to a hospital because he
definitely should go to a hospital if
his temperature is 93.9 on-call nurse
get in the car and drive your kid to a
hospital leaving him at home by himself
is one thing but this is a whole new
level of bad parenting the problem with
all this is there's no consistency
between this movie and the last one the
last one had a simple premise watch the
tape die in seven days this one seems to
be burned the tape Samara turns into a
prankster demon who develops new powers
and plot devices by the minute this is
apparently the first time rachel has
ever experienced a power outage holy
lady are you really too lazy to just
walk up the stairs and check on your kid
who was most likely asleep you'd rather
just yell and wake him up there's no
doubt I would be disturbed by this in
real life but mainly because I just
painted that assassin well then I'll
continue to be vague about it because
understanding why don't they keep
doctors nurses medicine and medical
equipment at Rachel's office if not I
have no idea why this is where she
decided to go wait I thought this was a
super boring town where nothing happened
why is the majority of the newspaper
staff still at work this late in the
evening yes there were lots of school
board meetings and cats and trees
[Music]
because when we're sleeping we don't
usually say anything so it's tough to
make out the words also how the haunt
your dreams while you were sleeping just
making shit up Freight and just say that
sounds creepy and forgot to make sure
that it made sense I hated this kid in
the last movie and now he's destroyed
all the goodwill he generated in the
first one I'm gonna go home and get some
of her things then we'll leave here and
never come back
because some are only operates in this
small Washington town she bought a house
here their family's here she volunteers
at a soup kitchen she's not moving
anytime soon also I'll leave you here
with the stranger who probably won't
believe me if I tell him the horrible
truth that you're possessed by a dead
girl and even though the stuff I'm
getting could probably wait until
tomorrow I'm leaving you here anyway
it's not the best water pressure that
works you don't need water pressure for
a bath those pictures that show Samaras
getting ever closer mostly make me
wonder why she waited so long to possess
Aidan in the first place
and why she didn't just jump right on in
instead of whatever this is man demons
ever hate open doors it's number one on
their list of turn offs ahead of people
who use their their and their wrong and
Hitler Samara starts flooding the house
again because she loves home alone Samar
decides to open the door because
DreamWorks paid a lot of money for this
special effect whoa um mom can you come
back and like go five minutes that's a
really good question Aidan because she
could do all this then why the hell did
she ever bother with that damn tape also
Aiden uses the pronoun game in front of
a stranger so that he'll think he means
Rachel and not some chick who was thrown
into a well by her parents and made a
videotape that whenever someone watches
it they die in seven - oh you're right
it sounds stupid when you put it that
way
having some kind of dream that's America
not here she could be a part of or
something I know this sounds great but
Rachel decides to cryptically explain
Samara story leaving out crucial details
and also playing the pronoun game so she
actually ends up sounding crazy also did
she just insinuate that getting Samara
out of the well and burying her allowed
her to do all this crazy if that's true
then why did she continue with her
standard mo she could have just
possessed and killed whoever she wanted
immediately instead of doing all that
bull but the videotape this is like the
genie being free but still living in the
lamp and granting wishes and tell me why
she's when did you prove this hypothesis
did you take pictures of Aiden after you
saw these I wish some are made a sequel
to her best-selling ring video and it
might be just as terrible as this sequel
is also did Samara co-director video and
this memory with Salvador Dali have you
left alone abandoned doctor if I may I
believe I have recorded evidence of
Rachel habitually abandoning her child
if you just go to iTunes and search for
word the ring god damn Rachel risks
whispering this while child services and
several doctors who are already pissed
at her are in here ah surprise Gary Cole
also creepy house Rachel needs to
investigate just so happens to have an
open house on this very day at this very
hour I'm sure the Morgans had other
things hanging on the walls in their
house yet the mirror from the video was
the only thing that left a lasting mark
on the wall even with Samaras newfound
omnipotence that I'm sure rachel is well
aware up she decides to go into the
basement of her childhood house alone
any banal movie moment can sound creepy
if you had creepy sounds to it I know
mother so I can't really speak in the
situation after taking just one look
into that basement probably say well my
kid had a good run leave and then the
movie would be over Hey look
antlers because the movie had that
moment with the deer earlier I still
don't know what it means or how it fits
into the story at all I mean tomorrow a
deer hunter or was she guilty by
association of knowing a deer hunter or
did she watch the deer hunter it's
interesting how the only things in the
basement are the creepy props we saw in
the first chapter of this story how
convenient the first new thing we see
leads Rachael right to Samaras
biological mother and this whole time I
thought Rachel would need hard work to
figure this out
no wonder Samaras fucked up her mom made
her the creepiest scrapbook ever article
entitled young daughter in bathtub which
means virtually nothing has a story
under it bed is nothing but vague
nonsense but you better believe that
three different paragraphs of that
nonsense were circled gosh darn it
a light goes out in the basement because
I guess Samara is near but nothing
happens Rachel leaves the house without
incident or running into Gary Cole again
and the only payoff for all those lights
going off is Eden waking up this
disappointment basically sums up this
entire movie he was at ninety seven
point two earlier but he went straight
back down and ninety point three and
nobody noticed that yeah lady no do you
see that giant monitor behind him
Eden news now Samara is going to make
dr. temple pull out this needle and
plunge it into her own neck I don't know
how she knew there was a needle there or
that sticking this needle with Aaron it
would kill her but props Amara props
hospital security is so lacks this kid
is able to kill a doctor get dressed and
mosey out without anyone noticing
that's Amara she never cried never
except when her mother would try to
bathe her Samara has the same weakness
as the aliens and signs movie
relentlessly reminds us of what
everything is in relation to that
flashbacks a maiden transferred to reach
and all those pictures she'd been
collecting they finally made sense and
those pictures ended up in a suitcase
that's been explicably in the basement
of Samaras adoptive parents house and
Aiden's walk home from the hospital was
completely psychotic dear list every few
years just like a freaking patron saint
or something got a problem with you kid
don't it's the movie now trying to tell
me that Samara is possessing children
but their mother's showing up to talk to
Evelyn is a regular thing and implying
Samar has been running a successful
possession side business in addition to
her seven days death tape and these
mothers had the wherewithal to
investigate Samara origins to the point
that it led them to this psych ward and
a possession was her game all along
surely one of those attempts would have
been successful over the years right
I know it yeah they all do it's never
seemed weird to me all these mothers
knowing the very song Evelyn sings
basically I just think everyone is crazy
so I'm never disappointed you get a
feeling on the exact day that someone
decides to come here something that
requires massive amounts of
investigation and people breaking
privacy laws to help find you yes
wait a minute are you saying that all
the other mothers who came here didn't
know about Samara they just had a kid
who was acting weird and somehow ended
up finding Samaras mom you see this is
some half-written booth nobody tried to
figure this out before it got filled are
you sure because your baby seems pretty
pissed about it okay fair but what did
Evelyn do was there some evil vinyl
record that kills you in seven days that
she let her baby listen to I guess if
you don't actually have a compelling
scary story to tell spouting cryptic
eerie sounding lines like this is the
next best thing that isn't amazing about
face to what you said just a minute ago
Evelyn was supremely unhelpful until the
movie enforced a time limit on this
visit you can't really leave till the
hospital says it's okay how do you know
they didn't you're not coming from the
hospital there wasn't some mad search
for the missing kid and don't you wonder
how he got here yeah he walked but don't
you naturally assume he got picked up
and taken here max thinks Aidan won't
see this obvious red blinking light and
then doesn't notice Aidan taking a peek
at the camera Max's tombstone will read
he died of ignorance so did the hospital
liver tried to call Rachel about her kid
leaving and the dead psychologist and
did she ever go to the hospital to check
up on him the thought of Aidan hugging
me may be almost as frightening as the
thought of Samarra killing me either
Samara bothered to put max in a truck
after killing him or if she did all her
usual ghost stuff to him and he ran out
of the house started the truck and then
died by the way I'm not buying this I'll
just leave you here in a running truck
we're only in the middle of a
neighborhood where I guess nobody
notices things like a truck running all
morning and night with the guys sleeping
on the drivers wheel
she sleep all the time now but only now
do you guys get to talk in your sleep
for some reason I mean I guess it's
possible Rachel hasn't slept since Eden
told her we have to sleep earlier but
more infuriated that this is even a
thing
also whoo Aidan has inception dream
powers that allows them to have the
shared dream earlier in the movie Sissy
Spacek predicted this because she said
her baby Samara told her something
similar to this
so I guess Samara was also possessed by
herself I thought you didn't sleep never
sleep see also what happens when Aiden's
little human body dies of sleep
deprivation also Samaras possession
absolutely hinges on the mom being ok
with her kid never sleeping you'd think
Samara would have learned how to fake
sleep just so she could keep the ruse
going but we're dealing with a very
stupid ghost here could be she's still
just a kid too but you'd think after
30-some odd years of doing this she'd
learn something is max still hanging out
in the truck being dead did she even try
to hide this body until she figured out
what to do with Aiden I don't know who
Tony Ventura is but whoever he is he's
going to have trouble sleeping tonight
also those pills Rachel crushed into the
PB&J actually made Samara fall asleep
listen she a ghost or a demon or
something
or is this movie saying Samaras asleep
because Aidan's body is asleep pop can I
give up these pills will knock a child
out for hours or until they are almost
pushed completely underwater
I'm still wondering how killing your son
is going to both free him of Samara and
keep your son alive but I'll just go
with it at this point
Oh wasn't that nice of Samara she
emptied the tub as she left so there
wouldn't be any continued drowning she's
taking this kind of well actually oops I
said well in front of Samara gotta stop
doing that except for the dead body
outside that's not all right and the
dead psychologist and the negligent
Hospital and the fact that I almost
drowned you but you're alive I'm alive
happy ending is there any reason why we
can't just throw the TV out the window
before she slowly walks to the screen
maybe she should also take an acting
class or two so that she doesn't do
weird in front of the potential mothers
that makes them want to drown her also
are you saying you were wrong about her
mo at the end of the first movie are we
just changing it to fit the narrative of
this movie and hoping no one notices
also okay I'll accept that Samara just
wants mommy now and is gonna put the
video tape murders on the back burner
but that still brings me to ask what was
wrong with Anna Morgan
Samaras adopted mother from what I know
she seemed like a nice enough lady but
Samara killed her horses and burned
scary images in her brain which
ultimately led her to kill Samara and
kill herself you had a perfectly good
mom Samara and you did all up and now
you want to be the child of a woman who
isn't even there for her kid half the
time Samara drags Rachel into the
television to claim as her mother
because that really how this works
Samara is afraid of water that she lives
in the well instead of well adjacent in
the house that was featured in that
video
rachel is now in the well by herself
there's some sort of preparation Samara
has to go through before making Rachel
her official mom is the mayor being a
dick about the parade routes again yeah
but she also uses a video tape to get
around it so I don't know how physically
closing this well matters she climbs in
and out of this thing all the time and
climbing at a much faster clip you'd
think she'd be able to catch up with
Rachel but you'd be wrong spirit world
water and rocks knock spirit world
veteran Samara down this well okay fine
she's jumping off the cliff to get back
to the real world but why isn't there a
distant TV somewhere she could jump into
isn't that what Samara does or does
Rachel just not know the elvish word for
friend could you just tell him what
happened the last movie of everything up
by not telling your kid but in the
second one you're all like nah I won't
tell him how I closed the well and
everything he wouldn't understand just
call me Rachel at least that is all he
ever called you until this one time
after you asked him to promise something
he said Rachel about five times and this
one scene alone you mean the original
director of Ringu and Ringu to direct at
this movie I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say he didn't have as much say in
this film as he would a lie
cut them into the fire
[Music]
he's not here mrs. Torrance
but that was awesome you brought me here
to watch a video alright there's just
too much pressure but with my job the
kids traffic snarled political strife at
home and abroad but I promise you the
second all those things go away
we'll have sex
[Music]
well I asked you to copy edit it and you
rewrote it I walked by gave yours a
glance it didn't look right so I just
figure out and finally the first
paragraph has to have more clarity if
the reader is going to understand you
don't mention Coulson's name for the
third paragraph